uh
all right
cheers
and uh budget chairman john yarmuth
okay
i didn't get that
okay
okay very good all right thank you
like this
is
i tried
no they got 28 witnesses
this is going to pass
when they said saturday the first time
maybe they were on yeah
is
i tried deliberately
um
this morning
3am on saturday
you know the problem
uh
that's not okay
um
up
all right
hmm
uh
okay
um
everyone didn't bring some guys
you
okay
517
you missed that
hmm
um good evening everyone
uh as we end this week we think back to
how we began
uh when our country crossed a very sad
uh number and that was that over 500
000 people had died of the coronavirus
and so many millions more
have been affected tonight
we are in rules committee awaiting the
their product so that we can bring to
the floor
legislation that saves lives
and saves the livelihoods of the
american people
it's a great day for us whether
when we take this vote we will take a
vote
to reduce the spread of this virus to
put
as we keep saying vaccinations
in the arms of the american people money
into the pockets
children into the schools workers back
into their jobs
so that we can go forward i salute
a president biden for his american
rescue plan
which will do just that rescue the
american people
uh the loss of jobs the loss of income
the loss of life first and foremost
i want to salute that the committee
chairs
who did such excellent work putting
together this legislation
with great precision so that it would
honor
the 51-vote privilege
it took time uh it took the knowledge
it took values and it took strategic
thinking to get the job done and then it
was handed over
to the chairman of the budget committee
we could not be better served
a budget should be a statement of our
national values what is important to us
as a nation
should be reflected priorities that will
have
our budget and indeed that is how
german you are always that is the
narrative of his leadership
as chair of the budget committee it is
my honor to now yield to him
so that he can give us a report as to
where we are on this very very
important reconciliation bill a budget
which is a statement
of our values to save the lives and
livelihood
of the american people mr yarman
thank you madam speaker this process
began 25 days ago
when we introduced the reconciliation
resolution
we've made remarkable progress in those
25 days and
and i want to echo the speaker and
complimenting all the committee chairs
when you think about the committees that
have been involved in this process
everybody from the agriculture committee
to energy and commerce to education to
science to veterans affairs
across the board you realize three
things
one is the breadth of the impact of the
pandemic
in both personal and economic terms the
many ways in which the
pandemic has affected this country in
virtually every corner of society
and finally third the magnitude of the
response that's required
and i think that's what you see
reflected in this legislation
an incredible piece of work that deals
with the pandemic
in all of its manifestations and in a
way that will
truly be effective in not only stopping
the virus
stopping the pandemic helping our
citizens get through
uh the economic challenges that they've
had
and also then helping our state and
local
governments in rebuilding the economy
getting set to rebuild the economy
i think you also realize why this piece
of legislation has such broad support
just this week a poll 76 percent of the
american people support the bill
60 of republicans you see everyone from
the chairman of the fed to major
business groups 150
ceos to education groups to labor groups
you can't name really one aspect of
society
that has not gotten behind this piece of
legislation
so we believe that this is something
that
is it meets the moment this bill meets
the moment
meets the challenge and we think it's a
great victory for the american people
and will get us
finally out of this terrible crisis that
we've been facing
thank you very much mr chairman i know
you guys have done a lot of work
and i hate to disagree with the chairman
he says this started 28 days ago
uh mr chairman you mean literally in
terms of your work on the budget
committee
i get that but it's important for us to
remember
this started almost a year ago
and a year ago we saw a crisis
confronting the american people
individually children
families grandmas grandfathers
businesses our economy generally
and so we have responded
five successful times two on our own
that unfortunately died in the senate
which if they had passed in the senate
we may not have needed this bill
and five times we passed legislation to
respond to this
crisis overwhelmingly in a bipartisan
fashion
and we will see shortly whether
some are going to stay the course in
responding to the crisis confronting our
people and our economy
more than half a million of our fellow
americans have now died
from this disease
hard to contemplate anybody thinking
that somebody
would attack us and kill five hundred
thousand of our people
but that's what covet 19 has done 10
million more americans are out of work
than at this point last year today's
vote is a crucial step in our fight to
defeat covet 19
and build our economy back better
i hope we will see the senate passed
version return to the house for the
final action within the next two weeks
we need to pass this bill prior to march
14th
so that on some millions of people are
not uh
falling through the cracks we are
determined to send the american rescue
plan to president biden's desk before
march 14th so we can begin providing
american workers businesses schools
communities men women children
with the assistance they need so
crucially need
economists agree that we need a bold
plan not just another temporary measure
mark sandy the chief economist of
moody's analytics said that another
relief package is needed
to get the other side of the package a
joint analysis of the american rescue
clan by the hamilton project
and brookings estimated that it would
boost economic activity
by 4 this year
that's the kind of shot in the arm the
economy needs madam speaker
real gdp would remain below the
pre-pandemic level for the next
several years however so delay
is not an option
failure is not an option retreating from
the support of the american people that
the five bills we passed in a bipartisan
fashion reflected
is not an option in a poll of economists
conducted by
reuters over 90 percent
said the american rescue plan would
boost the economy significantly
we must we must enact a bill
that reflects the urgent needs of our
country and meets the crisis we confront
that is a moral imperative as well as a
legislative imperative
and i now yield to mr clyburn
uh thank you mr leader for healing thank
you madam speaker mr chairman thank you
so much sir
and to my colleagues thank you for the
tremendous work you have
given to this effort as you just heard
over 70 of the american people are in
favor
of this plan in fact earlier this week
170 ceos
written a letter to the congress asking
that we pass this plan
the vast majority i think 50 6 56
of small businesses
have asked us to please
pass this plan the american
rescue plan builds a foundation for
coordinated public
private partnerships and
a compassionate response
to the needs of families
and communities for us to get
beyond this pandemic
i feel certain that we're gonna pass
this bill tonight
i mean a solid way
and i'm hopeful uh that the senate
will also respond to this
with a solid response so that the
american people
can begin to feel better about
themselves
and their future and with that uh i
think i'll get back to you madam speaker
i'll gladly entertain your questions and
the speaker will answer them
thank you very much mr clever and i
thank the distinguished
whip and the distinguished majority
leader as well as our chair
of the budget committee uh other members
of the leadership are here as
resource intellectual resources to
answer any questions that you may have
we all though gather with great pride in
the
the legislation that members will be
receiving
when it comes from the rules committee
where it is still
under consideration but it is a it it's
a great
we're going to make a giant step forward
tonight any questions
yes sir madam speaker do you agree with
some of the members of the democratic
caucus that believe
that the senate should either overrule
the parliamentarian's decision on
minimum wage or
break up the filibuster in order to keep
minimum wage as part of this package
well i invite any of my colleagues who
wish to answer that question to join me
as a matter of practice i don't
get involved in the rules of the united
states senate
but as a matter of values i can just say
we will not rest until we pass the 15
minimum wage we have been engaged in the
fight for 15
for a long time this is legislation that
affects
overwhelming the majority of women
so over 60 percent of the people make
the minimum wage
are women many are moms
and it is so essential for us to do this
and whether it happens when we send this
over there
we are sending it as a symbol
of a difference it'll make in the lives
of the american people
but not just a symbol but as a
solid proposal if it doesn't prevail
because senate rules
will persist but we will not stop
until we very soon pass
the fifteen dollar minimum wage any
other comments suppose one make one
that's something from their malaysia
yes ma'am are you do you think that this
issue specifically
raising the federal minimum wage that is
an issue that can cost democrats the
house and the senate in 2022
there's going to be a level of apathy
that develop um
there's going to be a level of apathy
that develops among
people that voted to send democrats to
congress and hope to bold change
and will argue that democrats aren't
doing enough to make this happen
we are determined to make this happen so
i don't want to answer a hypothetical if
we don't have
we have come here to get this job done
mr clyburn did you want to speak to that
do i want to
okay uh no we are going to do this um
i think that the speaker's correct
that's why we're keeping it
in our bill if we were going to be
political about it
i think we will all just take it out of
the bill no
we are doing this because we are
responding to the american people we
are uh that body here in the congress
that's closest to the american people
we think that 15 an hour
ought to be the law of the land we'll
see what the senate
does uh if they don't agree
we will come back with an independent
standalone piece of legislation
and we're going to pass it again and
hope
that they respond now the only thing
that's causing us the problem right now
is the parliamentarians rule and they're
going to abide by the rules i think the
president
is not going to advocate
uh that the vice president overruled the
parliamentarian
and we see what happens with the other
alternatives uh
after we pass it again if you don't do
it this time
just say that um we have been
on this for a long time uh when we won
the house the first
uh in this century the first time in
2006
in the first 100 hours not days
the first 100 hours we passed
an increase in the minimum wage it had
not been increased for 11
years and we passed an increase in the
minimum
wage it was part of our six for o6
that would be january 2007
when went to the senate it had the
wholehearted support of senator byrd of
west virginia
who put out a statement urging the
senate to take
up and pass the legislation because it
was so necessary
this is not a provision in a bill that
is accepted or not by the senate
this is again a value this is a
priority we will get it done and
again we'll study what the opportunities
are to do that
but let's not be distracted from what is
happening
in this legislation we have
a family of four getting what fourteen
hundred dollars
times four fifty six hundred
dollars a family of four individuals
getting the 1400 to bring it to two
thousand dollars
for this um uh series of of uh
direct payments half the children
poor children america will be taken off
of
poverty with the child tax credit
and especially addressing younger
children
in poverty small under six-year-old
children in poverty
the earned income tax credit will be a
boon
to those who are working and get the
earned income
tax credit the uh unemployment insurance
which
some of it which expires the middle of
march will be extended as well as the
expanded benefit for
that not to mention well
to mention the funding for for schools
so that
our children can go back to school
safely
the funding for the vaccine it's
distribution
it's a production distribution and
ministering it
into the arms uh that funding tens of
billions of dollars
so if you're talking about crushing the
virus
this legislation goes way down the road
to doing that if you're talking about
putting money in the pockets of the
american people this
is going to be a boon for families in
our country
working families if you're talking about
getting our children back into school
safely billions of dollars to do
just that in a way that is safe and
addresses
those schools which are a drastic need
for better ventilation and separation
and the rest if you're talking about
helping the food insecure millions of
food insecure children in america
their needs are addressed addressed with
the food security money that is in the
benefit and those
who are insecure with housing and on
verge of eviction the funding is there
a better uh way to attract
to a attend to the small businesses in
the rest this is a spectacular
piece of legislation while the senate
has prevented us temporarily
from passing one aspect of it let us not
be distracted from what is in here
because
it is a great bill any other comments on
the bill
i just have one comment on the electoral
implications of this eva
i think the more important question is
what kind of price are the
republicans both in congress and outside
who have opposed this
oppose this help to the american people
oppose raising the minimum wage
what kind of price are they going to pay
yes sir was that
is that your sales pitch to the
progressives in your caucus who
two weeks from now may have to vote
without having the minimum wage
is that what your sales pitch we have a
consensus in our caucus
that we're here to get the job done for
the american people this isn't about any
sales pitch
this is about who we are and uh
so many of the aspects of the bill have
been constructed
by our members we think it's a it's a
great opportunity for our country
you'll be able to pass it with or
without minimum wage absolutely this is
a good question
when the bill comes back who called on
you did somebody
you looked at me
i'm happy
when the bill comes back obviously there
will be changes you hear that someone
some in your caucus will look at this
and say
we want the perfect bill and the perfect
could become the enemy of the good is
that a concern when
does anybody think that there's any
chance that we do not pass
there is uniform support for this
transformational
legislation in the house democratic
caucus
there is no fair to partly cloudy view
of the american rescue plan it's a sunny
aspirational bold view because the 1.9
trillion dollar plan
as the speaker indicated will crush the
virus provide direct relief to the
american people
increase the direct payment survival
checks to a total of two thousand
dollars
provide 25 billion dollars in assistance
to renters and homeowners
who are struggling increase the
food security ebt program by 15
provide 350 billion dollars in state and
local assistance
so we can protect public programming
public safety public health public
education
public housing public transportation and
the provision of the public good
and those are just the highlights
that's not the fine print because it's a
once in a century
pandemic and the caucus under the
leadership of speaker pelosi has
recognized with the full support of
everyone
that it requires a once in a century
continuing comprehensive
and compassionate congressional response
and that's exactly what the american
rescue plan represents
i think that our unity around this bill
comes from the stories that we've
heard in our districts and i just want
to use
one woman whose story has come to my
attention
in my district and how transformative
this bill will be for her
she lost her job shortly after the
pandemic
lost her apartment and lost her child
care and didn't have a way to
be able to feed her young child or
afford diapers
what this bill and i'm so grateful to
the leadership of my colleagues and the
speaker
will say to her one of the one
in four american women who've been
forced out of the workforce
of the one of the people that of the 140
000 jobs that were lost in december
every single one of them was held by a
woman
and predominantly women of color this
bill will say to her there is a child
tax credit that can help lift your child
out of poverty
there will be a survival check to help
you put a down payment on a new
apartment
there will be food available for you
there will be vaccines and testing
so that your job you can get back to
your job
this is what this bill means to
americans that we
see them and that is why we are so
united behind this and it's just not the
democratic caucus it is the american
people because we are seeing them and we
are meeting their tremendous suffering
and loss
with tremendous solutions and help
so i am so grateful uh to this caucus
and to the work that has been done
and we look forward to delivering this
for all of those who have struggled
through this last year
so mightily and to restore that hope to
our communities
that is why this bill is so supported by
our caucus
this is an important bill for for our
caucus and for our country
i want to thank chairman yarmouth and
the budget committee members
who have done the work to get us this
far and the committee chairs
in addition to the members of leadership
behind me
this bill has the support of our caucus
because it meets the needs of our
communities
that's that's our guiding that's our
guiding principle and we know that we
know that it has
the public support as chairman yarmouth
mentioned
the question is will the other side
acknowledge that will they acknowledge
that this bill provides benefits because
when i
and i'm not the only colleague on this
stage who has had conversations
with local leaders who enthusiastically
support
this bill as chairman jeffrey said
because it protects the public good
public transportation public education
local local money for our local
our local communities that's why this
bill is good in addition to
the money for vaccine distribution that
meets the needs of our communities
that's important and our colleagues
recognize that and that's why i share
the confidence
and the sunny view as the chairman
mentioned
that we will pass this bill and then we
will pass it
again because it is good for the
american people
if i can just build on the vice
chairman's point add my thanks to the uh
speaker pelosi leader hoyer with clyburn
chairman yarmouth he's done
extraordinary work and all the chairmen
uh but i did a press event today
um three of the four county executives
in my district which is a very
conservative district are republicans
all three support this legislation uh
two appeared with me today
so i think i think it's important not to
miss the broad bipartisan support for
this package
as soon as you step out of the
republican caucus room the fact of the
matter is is that
county executives town supervisors
people on the front lines
who are responsible in many cases for
for administering the vaccine for being
the public health provider
in america they get it they understand
this is a long
dark night but there is joy in the
morning if we can
come together around this rescue plan
for the american people
it's not just the republican caucus that
matters
it is the millions of republican voters
who have said
they support this legislation 75 of the
american public
75 percent that includes large numbers
of republican elected officials who are
on the record
saying we need it and we need it now and
so i would i would point not just to the
unity of the democratic caucus but the
broad bipartisan support for this
package
it's a it's a very strong piece of
legislation thank you
thank you as i thank my members of the
leadership for
just that their leadership in all of
this and all that that entails i also
want to acknowledge as i have the
chairman of the budget committee and the
many other chairs
who were part of constructing this
proposal
this legislation and i want to thank
their staffs
because we have wanted to stay on
schedule
and that has meant 24 7 on the part of
the members
but especially on the part of the staff
so please convey the gratitude
of the leadership to to the staffs now i
also
along with a lot of kentucky bourbon
it's talking about kentucky bourbon
[Laughter]
you aren't giving that big daddy or big
papi or whatever his name is
in any case i also want to acknowledge
the staff
of the country one of the big provisions
of this bill and
the support for our our heroes
honoring our heroes you've heard me say
that many times honoring our heroes
putting money in the pockets of the
american people crushing the virus
again and putting our children safely in
schools but the schools can't function
and all the other things can't happen
unless we support our heroes those who
work at the state and local level
our health care workers our
transportation
sanitation food workers our first
responders police and fire ours
our teachers our teachers our teachers
and when we talk about the funding in
the bill for education
in light of covid well that does that's
one piece of it but
90 over 90 percent of the funding for
education comes from state
and local government and that's why we
have to have
that support in the legislation as well
because of revenue lost
because of shutdowns and because of uh
costs from covet that were unanticipated
and the healthcare workers people talk
about of their heroes
how do we thank them well we thank them
than letting them keep
their jobs a million more than a million
uh of of local employees have been
have lost their jobs because of the the
uh
the
loss of revenue from the shutdowns so in
any case
uh for every every way that we come at
this legis
uh this challenge that we have this
bill uh addresses it and pretty soon
it will be passed in the congress in the
house sent over to the senate
to be further engrossed to pass and go
to the white house
so that it is in time for the march 14th
deadline
i would like it well before that the
sooner we pass the bill
and it is signed the sooner we can make
the progress
that this legislation is all about
saving the lives
and the livelihood of the american
people thank you very much
good evening
you have some uh
all right